it was uh I think Lauren Southerners had
this that uh the Chauvin verdict was it
was a serious blow to the black lives
matter movement because they got their
verdict I mean so I I didn't listen to
her full argument I just saw it
passively mentioned by one of my friends
like oh look what she was saying and I
thought about it and I'm like
I I don't know exactly what her idea was
but the general idea that the Chauvin
virtue is bad for them it's true they
need the victim narrative they need to
claim the system opposes them but they
just handed you like guilty on all
counts across the board it did two
things it hurt the victim thing but that
won't matter because they'll keep
running with that because systemic
racism but what it also proved is that
domestic terrorism works and they got
the verdict they wanted because every
single potential juror what did they say
I'm scared the mob's gonna come to my
house well I don't think every jurora
said it every week I thought everyone we
had a few people during the the jury
selection where they were like yeah I'm
worried about this a little bit and then
we had the one alternate who came out
and said I didn't want to go through
riots and destruction again and I was
worried they'd show up to my house in
retaliation and I'm like she ain't
talking about Trump supporters no ain't
no Trump supporters writing and chugging
people's houses to do that right all
right we'll talk about the capital sure
that's the seat of politics it was a bad
thing but in terms of afternoon right in
terms of the past year not Trump
supporters right and the idea for for
black lives matter they now have learned
over the course of last year's
Insurrection and this year's
Insurrection that if they threaten
violence they get what they want they're
tweeting that they're bragging about it
that's the definition of domestic
terrorism right and so it's time you
know when we get it the Reigns of power
again the FBI said that there's no
evidence and that it's white supremacy
that's the real threat so you know these
people can romp around and do whatever
they want no one seems to care but I
wonder if there's going to be a backlash
oh there's a backlash Brewing because
one of two things is going to happen Law
and Order is going to be reasserted you
know and we'll have one standard for all
Americans like to what is the 14th
Amendment I suck at amen 14th okay thank
you yeah and that has to be true and
right now it's not all right there are
two tears of justice and they want like
you said black lives matter won but
that's not going to stop their victim
mentality because systemic racism says
that the entire system has to change not
just win one Victory they're winning due
to domestic terrorism not because
they've overturned the system and
replaced it with with equity and because
there is no one uh no one to stop it
there's no law enforcement agency
there's no military there's no police
and this is why uh
you know I've been saying you know it's
great about the police
I left the city because we saw the riots
getting worse
I had a good local Suburban police
department they were they were cool
dudes they helped me out when I had
problems they were at my house in in a
moment's notice those guys are all right
in the city proper
they couldn't handle anything I mean the
the cops are better at locking up
conservatives who didn't wear masks than
they were the rioters because because
the DA's for the most part so I look at
it now and I'm thinking you've got right
now Ted wheeler in Portland saying
please help us unmask these anarchists
these these people and it's like bro you
were supporting these people last year
you were outstanding side by side with
them complaining about Trump while they
were throwing firebombs you come out now
and say now you're trying to stop them
okay he exploited the anger against
police while the the city was on fire
okay well buildings in the city were on
fire I know the fact Checkers going to
be like that's not true the city didn't
burn the ground and now he's coming out
and saying I need your help to stop them
he's got mug shots out of him when they
arrested him last year and let them go
that's right we just put the mug shots
out so these cops here's what here's
what I'm angry about so you mean to tell
me that you're a cop in Portland and the
police the mayor throws you under the
bus
and then he uses you and the anger
against you to get to get reelected and
then after he gets reelected he says
okay now I want to arrest him and and
these cops are like that sounds good
I'll keep licking his feet like
at what point do you stand up for
yourself at what point do you as an
officer live on your feet because right
now I'll tell you this every single
police officer in Portland is a
groveling sniveling little weasel
sucking up to Ted wheeler the police can
actually agree with the the left enough
that they don't care and here's the nice
thing though okay here's here's my
solution to that I'm I'm the Mr solution
man but let's do the great sort and
let's have blue State and red State
policing if they want to have gutless
weasel policing in the cities and not
arrest people or let them go and do
those kind of things gym owners okay
yeah and do that then let's have the gym
owners leave and let's take the cops who
have you know enough intestinal
fortitude to say I'm not going to put up
with that and lick the boots and let's
have them move to the red States and
they'll be our cops yeah I'll hire those
guys in a heartbeat the cops that aren't
willing to stand up for move to Florida
Texas Oklahoma Montana and let's start
the sword it's the great sort into our
tribes let's do the Federalist thing and
move to where people share your values
and one of my values is don't break the
law and steal my stuff or hurt me I'm
like look if you want to live in
Portland do so with my blessing right
you want to live in Minneapolis by all
means your choice you want to live in
New York absolutely and then when they
come and burn your house down and then
the cops arrest you because you weren't
wearing a mask when you flood your home
what do you want me to do about it I'll
laugh if it was I'm watching on TV from
my house in Red State America you're
gonna like it they're gonna throw a
mouth off at your house and the cops are
going to be like peaceful protest you're
going to start run out of your house
where's your mask you got a vaccine
passport no but that's that's good see
that's I it's the idea that things had
to get worse so people would pay
attention so now we got the normal
people have been affected by this and
the normals we're sitting you know doing
their stuff I think a lot more sure
every day not enough right but every
time they do something crazy it takes
one more person who says that's
ridiculous yeah but the issue is
while this is going on right here's what
happens the cops in a city like
Minneapolis or in the surrounding areas
do something and then these people who
are watching an escalation in crime and
violence are blaming the police still
they're like why aren't the police doing
their job and then the cops shows up and
there's a woman with a knife but a stab
another woman so the cop saves the one
woman they go why did the cop do his job
but okay there's no answer so so don't
work for them right let's do it yeah
that's the answer and that's if you're a
cop with enough you know self-respect to
go ahead and say I will not let someone
treat me like I I also wonder why it is
that so many conservatives even bothered
with fighting the abolish the place
thing in the first place yeah you don't
live in those cities right they voted
for look so so when when the leftists
are like stopping Frisk is racist and
Must Be Stopped I'm like I don't live in
New York not my problem you know you
vote you voted for the for the Democrats
and they appointed these people and now
you've got this policies from the police
department and you should probably stop
voting for these people or vote for
somebody else I don't know who you
should vote for I'm not saying because
they've had Republican and independent
Mayors as well but uh first of all okay
stop it first is bad I lived in New York
for some time uh I don't live there now
so why should I care if someone who
lives in New York votes to get rid of
their own Police Department hell why why
should I impose my will on a city I
don't live in let's stop Federal funding
of police departments that do stupid
stuff Trump tried to do something like
that when Portland Seattle were where he
was going to stop Federal funding going
to cities that allowed Chas chop type
you know insurrections to happen and did
nothing about it let's make that
absolutely don't give a dime of my money
I'm I'm actually at this point I'm kind
of like the if the left doesn't want
Cops in these major cities
I agree
I think most of the people there do them
because if you go and look at a poll are
they standing up going outside are they
voting for no voting for Democrats
they're voting they're voting for Kamala
Harris and they're not standing up
publicly for the police nah they can say
whatever they want to pollsters I know
what they really want well they're
showing it I'm actually I've been
thinking a lot about this and I'm like
you know what man when I lived in the
Philly area I was obviously in support
of the police why because they helped me
out the local cops I had we were it was
a Philly suburb they were good dudes I
went in there one day and I was like you
know I was trying I think I was getting
my firearms license I talked with cop
for a little bit he's an awesome guy we
talked about it we agreed and it was it
was a couple blocks away from my house
that kind of policing that's what AOC
said was a good thing she was like good
Suburban policing not like these Urban
centers so at this point I'm kind of
like you know what right on
I left I don't live in these areas
anymore I'm not going to impose my will
on you if you live there and you're
vocal and you say you don't want Cops
hey dude get rid of your cops with my
blessing and the criminals will
obviously stop criming once you stop
police from policing right I mean crime
will I think crime will get
substantially worse massively however is
it my choice I don't live there no and
it's not your problem and let that
happen I love the idea I know I can get
behind defund the police in your own
City exactly I will vote for an increase
to hire the good officers give them a
promotion and bring them to my area
exactly because and the other thing is
my neighborhood doesn't have a lot of
crime so we really don't have to spend
that much so why is there crime it's not
the police didn't bring the crime the
crime was there Minneapolis a major
Urban Metro wants to get rid of their
cops I think they should do it I do uh I
don't live there I know there are a lot
of people who live there who want police
but I'm sorry like the way the system
works is we all vote for Representatives
they go to to the seat of you know
government and they they represent us if
your your city is is is dominated by
people who don't want Cops I'm sorry man
do you have the right to be like well we
should have cops anyway or should should
you respect the will of the people who
want to live in crime infested you know
gang territory and we can shoot escape
from Minneapolis and all these
follow-ups for escape of New York but
listen I think a lot of conservatives
make the mistake of assuming these
people actually want police and it's
it's the craziest thing to me because
you know I talked about this last week
he had the story of the woman in New
York City runs up to the other one puts
a bullet in her head right no National
story no no protests no riots why stop
assuming they actually want police to
stop this they don't care I wonder I I
wonder if it's that or if they're cowed
in submission because there's an element
of if you've lived under those
circumstances you're essentially an
enemy occupied territory you know the
gangs the criminals the bad guys are a
lot scarier but when the cops aren't
there that often where's the where's the
where's the black lives matter activist
to Stage a protest I'm not saying they
have to and I'm not trying to play this
game of like they clearly don't care
about you know they only support no no
I'm saying if if they don't come out and
say this is something we care about want
solved I'm not going to assume they do
and I think a lot of conservatives look
at this they're like clearly people
would prefer to live the way we live and
I'm like maybe they like the violence in
the right I'm not kidding well and I
don't think the black lives matter
people have any interest at all in
fixing that that's not their game their
game is in gaining power so they use you
know black oppression under the police
as a grievance to gain power and
distribute it and see the ones who do
that so they're not going to fix that
that doesn't help them according to
Gallup something like 80 percent of
people in black neighborhoods want more
cops or or they want the same level and
then like 26 said even more but I'm like
listen if you tell me you want Cops and
then do literally nothing first of all
you can tell me you want something but
if you don't do anything to get it I
don't believe you I've said this for a
long time actions speak louder than
words I've had so many people say to me
like Tim I would love to do what you do
I remember when I was traveling around
the world and a bunch of young people
say Tim I want to go to Ukraine and
Venezuelan report on news too how do I
do it and I'm like buy a plane ticket
and just go and then go nah I'm not
doing that
and I'm like well then you don't want to
because if you did you'd do it I had so
many friends who are like I want to go
to uh you know Egypt and they just buy a
plane ticket and go and I'm like because
they wanted to but so many people say
they want something and they don't
really mean it so these people were like
yeah I want more cops will you stand up
and just say those words on your porch
in order to make it happen nah it's so
much work so then you're back to the
idea is there an advantage to Cruelty or
honestly pragmatism as a policy for the
side that opposes that and you're kind
of saying yes and I agree with you let
them suffer the consequences of their
own choices or lack of action why do you
say suffer go all right because they're
by an objective standard they may not
feel they're suffering enough to change
it but they are in my opinion somewhat
objectively suffering from the the
ravages of crime so that's exactly it
right imagine this you you you want to
you want the right to keep in bear arms
right sure you would like to have the
right to defend your own home should the
police or I'm sorry should someone break
in your house you want to be able to
defend your property and yourself yeah I
have that right and not right we do we
all have it
the leftists are saying these these
these people are crazy we're trying to
help you what is wrong with you there's
gun violence we are helping you how many
times have I heard it from leftists
where they're like why don't you accept
our government health care we're
literally just trying to help you and
you know because I don't want to live
that way so I looked at these cities and
they're like abolish the police and I'm
like yeah it's your your city not mine
and it's good you don't got to live like
me federalism says you do what you want
a you know gather your tribe live how
you want and guess what you get the
consequences of your own actions if you
do if you gather with good people who
don't commit crimes who want to you know
live and prosper guess what you get
Prosperity you get security and good
let's do that and I think the people who
who live in Minneapolis right now who
are of the mind that police are good and
they won't do anything about it maybe
because they'll get fired maybe they're
scared of retaliation
and I'll tell you this if that's true
you value your current position more
than you value the then you feel
threatened right so it's very simple if
you were if your house is on fire
and you felt like you were going to die
you'd run out of your house into the
street with nowhere to go because it's
better than being in a burning building
if you're in a house is on fire but it's
like a small kitchen fire in a pan you'd
be like it's no big deal someone will
put it out it's fine that's where
they're at right now Minneapolis they
don't realize what's happening and they
don't care they're like someone will
deal with it I'm fine here well they're
throwing water on a grease fire is what
they're doing you know and that's going
to blow up in their face and again so
here we don't have to care right exactly
so here's what it is right there's a
grease fire somebody sitting in the
living room they're like ah they're
putting it out but they're throwing
water on it right and and we're saying
like dude it's a grease fire throwing
water on it get out of the house now and
they're like yeah they're like I'll be
over here I know the fire is bad but
it's just
I'm in my pajamas am I gonna go outside
it's it's like cold out I might well
eventually the fire will get better for
they'll have no choice to leave and you
know maybe that's when people really
move but what I really see when I see
this is that the cops who don't quit
it's because they feel secure they don't
think they're going to be threatened by
this Kim Potter didn't think she'd be
Chauvin number two well here she goes
these cops don't believe it now we got
another cop in Elizabeth City North
Carolina I think seven cops three
resigned already apparently unrelated to
the incident they just resigned because
cops are resigning uh not too far from
here there's a police shortage in a
local town and they're like we got to
figure out what we're doing about this
because the good cops are already
quitting good the rest of them think
they're safe or the money's worth it
yeah and in in a lot of cases they're
not willing when you got a family and
you're living paycheck to paycheck
they're not willing to take that risk
and I can I can understand that but what
what are you gonna do the crocodile's
coming for you well you know it's gonna
eat you too imagine it this way you're
in a big house you're in living room
catches on fire you're sitting there
with your kids do you recognize the fire
as a threat enough to get your kids out
of the house before the fire it consumes
everybody and kills them or is someone
going to be like nah I'm fine and then a
month from now their their home is isn't
is in the newest autonomous Zone and a
straight bull that hits their kid right
and they like why didn't I leave when I
had the chance because you saw the fire
and you said I don't care I feel safe
and I feel fine nothing's gonna happen
and so be it you're entitled to it I'm
not telling you what you should or
shouldn't do I'm just saying it for me I
left I was like yeah I don't want to be
in the city with rice I think they're
not seeing the fire in their house
they're hearing the fire alarm go off
and it's it's been so many false alarms
that they're just ignoring the fire
alarm
I I was in a building when I worked this
hilarious story I worked for uh when I
was running for Fusion
a man uh it's like I think it's like the
fourth or fifth floor and I'm sitting in
that they had these little restaurant
booths in this big Loft space in New
York City I'm sitting with
um someone on my team
on our computers
all of a sudden you know the lights
aren't flashing
I'm like all right I immediately stand
up unplug my computer throw up my bag
and I'm like let's go to my teammate who
was like we're leaving I'm like the fire
alarms going off look at your bed let's
go and I I we we grab our stuff and we
start walking to the door no one's
moving and I'm like yo let's go and then
I leave the building and then I'm
standing outside and we you know the
fire department rolls up two trucks pull
up they the cop the fire fire department
they jump out there in full gear they
got their axes and they got their air
and everything and I'm like man what's
going on they rush in the building and
then a few minutes later one by one the
employees start coming out and I'm like
did you guys wait for the fire
department to tell you to leave the
building when the fire alarm's been
going off for like five minutes and they
were like oh we didn't know if it was a
false alarm or something
turns out there was a fire it was a
small fire found in the basement it
wasn't a big deal and I was just like
wow all of those people just stayed in
the building
and if the fire in the basement actually
did cover that for that front door
they'd all be dead that was amazing to
me apathy I mean it's what everybody is
they're they're too busy to think about
it too busy to do and they've been
scared to act you know that's the
biggest thing that freaks me out and
that it goes to your whole point of why
is nobody do anything because they're
scared of the consequences of action
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time